oh the trailers just don't stop you know
think about that as long as the trailers
don't stop the videos don't stop either
baby so now we have a trailer to x-men
apocalypse I was looking forward to this
one a lot of hate came out when people
saw apocalypse they were like alive in
tears no but I always felt the pictures
that made him look like Ivan is just
like a color correction thing all right
we'll see even in this trailer you don't
actually get a good look at apocalypse
you get one and when you see it you're
like all right it doesn't look bad at
all I like the detailing around his
armor it doesn't look plain it looks
interesting it doesn't really look like
I have a news but talking about the
trailer okay so the trailer starts out
gene Greg gets a vision she's like oh my
god the world's gonna end I saw death
which is played by the girl who plays
Sansa Stark and when she's talking I
just hear Sansa Stark because like Sansa
Stark this lines delivered through tears
I saw the end of the world I could feel
all this death Jane it was just a dream
you should probably listen to your
psychic student Xavier and the trailer
has a good tone to it they're all
talking about apocalypse of life this
guy is evil like the Four Horsemen of
the Apocalypse got that one for the
Bible oh okay so this is all like
biblical wrath [ __ ] without any of the
Jim Caviezel as a buffer I'm scared
there's just a frightening ass thing as
movies like yeah everything mankind has
ever known or learned or thought about
deity came from this guy nightcrawlers
back in this movie quicksilver's back in
this movie he's doing the requiem for a
dream running camera angles bang with
the cameras in front of him kind of
maybe chuckle but you also know that
shit's probably going down I'm just glad
he's back because I just felt like in
Days of Future past the most
advantageous power in the entire movie
is someone who can go that fast made for
the sweetest scene but I just feel like
the movie could have ended a lot sooner
he could have just solved a lot of
problems but speaking of the four
horsemen in this movie you have storm
Psylocke archangel and magneto which
that is a concern of mine and magneto
being one of the Horsemen of the
Apocalypse
I'm afraid they're gonna do it like
Charles Xavier and x-men - I mean x-men
- I thought was a great movie but Xavier
is really underutilized he's not really
in the movie a lot I feel like it might
be that case with magneto in this movie
where he's not in the movie a lot or
he's not doing a lot and even if he is
doing a lot in the movie it's not his ID
he's ultimately carrying out apocalypse
as well but then there's the argument
where he's like all right you want to
see a movie where Magneto's the villain
those are out there there are a few of
them so let's give a black ellipse a
shot now played by Oscar Isaac I was one
of the seven people who liked the
Russell Crowe Robin Hood when I was
watching the movie I was like I don't
know who that guy is but I want to see
even more stuff because that was great
in the movie and now Oscar Isaac he's
just taking over Hollywood he's in the
Star Wars movie he's in an x-men movie
his voice isn't the apocalypse that I
remember that it's much more human
I'm uses the animated series words like
our most well one of my favorite things
about this trailer is just it's the
simple moment where Xavier is on cerebro
and he looks scared out of his mind
because that's Charles Xavier I've never
actually seen him this frightened he
looks scared shitless which is when
after apocalypse is like he shows
Charles Xavier I love the look on his
face I'm not only because the fact that
his eyes turned black and that's just
really creepy but James McAvoy is a
great actor and this scene is why you
see a few emotions on that guy's face in
this one shot first of all he looks
scared out of his mind then it looks
like he's enjoying the power he is
feeling then it looks like he respects
that power I just love that scene I
watched just the end of this trailer
over and over and over again probably
watched it 10 times 2025 no more than
thirty five times I was looking forward
to this movie when I saw the after
credits scene in x-men Days of Future
past now we're here I think it's a great
ensemble cast and an ensemble of mutants
in the movie I just can't wait for the
apocalypse what can I say the end is
nigh where's our the trailer for x-men
apocalypse have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]